after defeating the government 14 times
to amend the EU withdraw bill those of
us in the House of Lords have been
accused of an unwritten shoe a power
grab that could derail breaks it repairs
have been called unelected wreckers
saboteurs rebels but tourism a wanted to
bypass Parliament altogether first by
trying to give us no say in the decision
to trigger article 50 then our
government wanted Britain to leave the
EU whatever the cost
with or without a deal but breaks it is
not take it or leave it
giving the houses of parliament to say
over the implications of brexit it's not
a power grab this is giving power back
to the people nor have the lords
weakened the government's negotiating
power in Brussels we want the best deal
in the best interests of the British
people even if that means staying in the
customs union and ideally also the
single market far from sabotage the
peers have given the British people
through Parliament a meaningful say over
breaks it that to me is true democracy
[Music]
I've got to keep a bit calm here ok so
currently you and your unelected cronies
have not only inflicted defeat on this
government but on democracy what you
have done is insult democracy you are an
enemy of democracy
not a single Britain voted for you or
any of the members of the House of Lords
and yet you have defied a government
voted for by thirteen point six million
people in the course of action voted for
by seventeen point four million people
you know this brings into question for
me the whole the whole of our democratic
system is it all of us everyone who are
involved in our system or is it a bunch
of rich connected elitists like yourself
who who think that by dint of their
education and their connections can you
know what's best for the nation you
actually said in the House of Lords on
one of the many votes where you've been
transitive feed brags that you actually
said you said that Parliament knows best
Parliament knows what's best for the
people and the country you forget your
role Karen you are the servants we are
the masters you do what we elected
you're not even elected how well let me
say this and that I'm Donna then I'm
gonna back end people have voted in
nothing they have they have connections
with Brussels there are there are no let
me finish there are 30 former any peace
who collect pensions they're allowed to
vote they're allowed to influence what
happens and I want to talk about the
percentage attendances you have attended
20 and 21 percent of debates this year
you've collected 11 grand in fees
attended much more than 21% oh no well
that's what's on the official record
Karen I check the official record and it
says 21% record in total it's far higher
than insulting me personally and you of
course are an elected individual aren't
you anyone who has a say has to be
elected do you realize the role of the
House of Lords if we lost intervening
Iori
we lost the House of Lords in the form
that it is and if you haven't
elected House of Lords the whole dynamic
will change at the moment the Commons
has the final say and we know that our
job is to revise review scrutinize
legislation and make the guardians of
the bonds not let's let's let's pull
back a second I just want to say that I
don't think you're my enemy or anybody's
and I mean I don't think you're my enemy
I'm talking about the house no I just
think was slightly a bit personal but
I'm with you and I always have been by
the way on the need for the house
windows to reform and I don't allow that
view of mine to swing or sway depending
on the political climate I'm very
consistent in that I do believe the
House of Lords needs to reform and I and
I think that actually it's very
interesting in this debate how the
tables have turned because it's always
been liberals with a small and big help
that have been calling for the House of
Lords to reform but now suddenly
conservatives are calling for it in fact
two-thirds of the public in our calling
yes and she's a I think a fantastic more
- you want to abolish the form is
different - abolition reform would
include an elective second what I will
say the last thing I'll say is that I
think while they're there before for me
and happen or has happened it is
important that they're allowed to do
their jobs which is scrutinized
legislation scrutinize shall we move the
debate on a little bit Kalyn because I
wonder if I can refer you to the front
page of today's Daily Mail no it's not
the picture of is there a danger that
with what you and your colleagues are
doing most of the time what you and your
colleagues do is a very valuable
exercise and don't take this wrong wait
you largely go unnoticed you largely go
unnoticed and it carries on if you
continue to do this are you not
concerned there could come a tipping
point where the level of anger that
we've seen we just don't have 10
personal but the level of anger that
we've seen from Carol
actually starts to really put in
jeopardy the importance of what a second
chamber does and I know you like me
collect copies of this newspaper indeed
this one this one featured you earlier
this doesn't mean it reflects the whole
term but you should be a revising
chamber absolutely no question I think
in this case Karen you're in danger of
becoming a rewriting chamber in that you
want to rewrite no not at all go ahead
because what if you think about what
we've done every piece of legislation
that comes from the commons goes through
all the processes and then comes to us
the university's bill last year we had
500 amendments in the House of Lords
because it's with our experience with
our expertise with peers of universities
giving their input that helped to
improve that legislation that then goes
back to the Commons and it's up to them
to accept it not here if you look at the
14 amendments that we won every one of
them there's a reason to give Parliament
to meaningful say the government is
saying we'll give you a vote at the end
on the final Deal or No Deal
but if you don't agree we crash out on
WTO deals probably to your rules I'm
sorry that is the public will not accept
that we're seing a meaningful vote means
if Parliament doesn't agree it means
maybe go back to negotiate or maybe even
remaining in the European Union if
that's the best option I just think it's
so interesting because brexit ears voted
for Britain to retain and we receive its
sovereignty so now we have the
sovereignty of British institutions
notably the two houses of parliament
suddenly they don't like how sovereignty
anymore because it produces a result
that's not what they say they want the
reality is you cannot cast the House of
Lords as subverting the will of the
British people because we don't know
whether the rich people voted for a hard
or soft brexit cuz the question wasn't
asked the question was do you want to
remain or leave that you know one was
asked about whether they want a customs
partnership or to get banned the way to
reign and building inherently and that
and that's not what people vote for the
bottom line is if you care so much about
parliamentary sovereignty why did why
didn't a lot of the guys or the lord
said gave away parliamentary sovereignty
40 years ago
well Brussels you've given it away by
the part of this whole non Smart's
giving away sovereignty you realize
we've had the best we've had the best of
both worlds I had seen well years 12
years I've seen the legislation that
affects our day-to-day lives is made in
our Parliament very little of it is the
ECJ having the final say most of our
case is a result
our ports at the ultimate that's what I
think it is it's fair to say that until
reform happens and this may well
encourage reform you're right though
heartedly it's about time but until
reform happens there are genuine
questions that need to be asked about
the way which we brexit to our fours
point and House of Lords need to be able
to do their jobs now some of these
genuine questions come around to the
arrangements between the customs union
and Britain and the single market and
even even our foreign secretary and was
pressed on this earlier let's let's
watch what he had to say about it the
Prime Minister has made it very clear
where she said in her imagine how speech
were coming out of the customs union
were coming out of the the single market
were taking back control of our of our
laws and will you resign as she said
we're coming out of the customs union
were coming out of legal muster core
issues and I have no doubt that that's
what she and the rest of the government
are going to deliver and so here there
are there are serious questions and I
think Carol all of us can agree that
they are quite substantive issues that
there seems to be a confusion even at
cabinet level and until until this
reform that you are so passionately
arguing for that I'd back you on happens
I think Karen should be allowed to do so
now peanuts also it and also look at the
reality is the government doing a good
job in negotiating so let's have a look
at the statistics let's have a look at
the statistics 56 percent of people
think the government is doing a bad job
in only 28 percent our job is Paul I
only respect people's it's our job as
parliamentarians to challenge government
continually on a day to day basis and
then order breaks it is not a blank
check it was not leave on any terms